[Music]
welcome back to Hannity joining us now
with more reaction of the Harvey
Weinstein scandal and Hillary Clinton's
hypocrisy counsel to the president
Kellyanne Conway
you know Kellyanne I've watched these
Hollywood phony hypocrites go after you
and go after the first daughter and go
after the First Lady of the United
States Oh Melania wore high heels to
representing the country
on her way to help serve people in Texas
and I'm watching how they've treated
women and then you see the Hillary
aspect of this and the donations from
Weinstein and the money from countries
that practice Sharia is this now just
the beginning of a real dialogue of
issues we've been pointing out for a
long time it Shawn it's clearly a
continuation of the hypocrisy of Hillary
Clinton and other femine so-called
feminists like her why let's go back to
the Oscars a few weeks ago can you
imagine for every unfunny political joke
that was told for every time the
president's name was invoked had we
replaced that with Weinstein or rape or
sexual predator or if somebody actually
had used her power on the stage there
were many so-called powerful rich
successful Hollywood women accepting
Awards giving awards what if one of them
over these many many years that this has
been going on allegedly what if one of
them stood up in front of a live TV
world wide audience and said you know
what instead of thanking my mother and
my third grade teacher and my producers
and my agents I'm going to tell you a
story about what goes on here in
Hollywood and I'm going to do that now
because when I was 22 I felt harassed
and belittled and cornered but now I'm
double that age and quadruple that
wealth and I'm successful I want to save
the next generation any woman out there
who remains silent as the next
generation suffered under the sexual
predatory culture in this man then they
are complicit here and they have no
right to stand up and say that they
speak for women now let's be clear about
something else when Hillary Clinton and
others since you mentioned her but many
others when they talk about quote
women's rights and women's health you
have to take one layer off and realize
they're really talking about abortion
they're often talking about abortion
when they say women's health it becomes
a euphemism for abortion
so when pro lifers say hey you know
maybe it's not such a great idea to have
an abortion in the 8th or 9th month and
they say a woman has a right to do what
she wants with her body hey folks hey
ladies a woman has a right to keep her
body free from sexual predators who are
threatening allegedly threatening them
if they don't comply or dangling goodies
Hollywood goodies in front of them if
they do comply so basically if you have
the right political positions Hollywood
will forgive all of Bill Clinton's
atrocious examples of abusing women
these weren't consensual relationships
Monica maybe yeah but not Kathleen
Willey Paul Jones Jennifer flowers or
maybe Jennifer was and but she was trash
for telling the truth or wanita
Broderick and will also forget Roman
Polanski because he's such an artist and
will forget that Hilary took all this
money from all these countries and they
bought her silence because she never
criticized the countries that donated so
many millions of dollars to the Clinton
Foundation that abused women the way
they do and persecute gays and lesbians
and Christians and Jews isn't that
really the truth here isn't that the
biggest hypocrisy of this the truth it
is it really was a major storyline last
year about the foundation taking money
from these countries that oppress women
and girls don't give them basic rights
that your daughter and my daughters and
me enjoy every single day
there's something else here I mean you
mentioned Bill Clinton just remember if
you talk about sexual harassment in the
workplace
he paid $800,000 to settle in money
that's money from 20 years ago so
imagine how much the value is now to
settle such a suit so Hillary Clinton's
got some experience in this space but
most importantly look at the
juxtaposition in my workplace just today
and what we're talking about in
Hollywood with all these so-called
feminists standing up for women's right
to remain silent and didn't help just
today in the White House Donald Trump
the president the United States did yet
again what he's been doing his entire
career he elevated another woman to a
position of power he'll be attacked next
his secretary Secretary of Homeland
security nominee that makes two women
that have the top two spots in Homeland
Security if she is confirmed
Elayne Duke the deputy and the new Madam
Secretary Kirsten Nelson and Kirsten of
course is the latest in any number of
women that president Trump has elevated
gave women a chance in New York real
estate when no man would certainly in
his corporation his campaign his White
House his cabinet and I thought it was
such a juxtaposition today to think
about what the two parties are dealing
with and also this is a president who
when he says I'm going to empower women
how did he do that today he signed an
executive order in health care that
helps millions of American women who
posed as have no health insurance Sean
it's huge and he's out there last night
with the truckers and others in
Pennsylvania promising them middle-class
tax relief that's the way you empower
women you help them when you're in a
position to do that these people in
Hollywood failed this president is
succeeding let me play you know last
night before the president arrived for
the interview and I can't let you go
without an important political question
I went through the crowd all right you
might argue okay this is a pro president
crowd because they were there to see him
I asked about the president they loved
the president I asked about the
Republicans in Congress I would assume a
lot of these people there are
Republicans and about the media watch
this reaction this was from the people
that were in Harrisburg last night the
Senate they're doing a terrible job they
need to get on board because if they
don't that what just happened in Alabama
you're gonna see happen a lot of play
that's the canary in the coal mine
absolutely how is the Congress doing
terrible Congress needs to get on board
and realized Donald Trump love him or
hate him he is what America picked so
the Republicans have the house in the
Senate you're angry at them yes yes live
in Congress not so fantastic but you
know I've I've hope that we can turn it
on what do you think in the news media
well I mean you guys are fabulous but
CNN is fake nose fake news fake did you
agree with that I totally agree with
that my new Fox are doing a fantastic
job true I'm true coverage CNN not so
much exact opposite I think that
ignorance on the left is horrible how
bad is the media who's the worst it's
fascinating the public gets it Congress
isn't doing their job well they get this
tax bill done Kellyanne because if they
don't they really do need to go they
need to they must because look what
happened today when Congress failed to
repeal and replace Obamacare the way
they all promised to do for eight years
eight months on the job
president Trump signs an executive order
and to actually give some relief and
open up some competition and choice so
he will take action every time he can
Sean outside the legislative process
where doesn't fail or where he's able to
act which he's done I look how much the
stock market and all the confidence
indicators love what this president is
doing when it comes to tax reform we're
very hopeful that Republicans will make
good on their own promises to their
constituents to give middle class tax
relief to make us more competitive to
keep the jobs and the wealth here in
this country and stop punishing our
employers and repatriate the 2.8
trillion dollars that's legally parked
overseas give a child care tax credit
expanded elder care tax credit and also
to do away with the marriage penalty the
death tax all these legacy businesses
this is the way you help people and when
it comes to the media I love the fact
that general Kelly our chief of staff
today took to the White House pressroom
media basically said you're lying they
are liars lying they do lie with
regularity and we pointed out all right
Kelly I'm great too so you don't need to
they don't need to we're accessible they
just have to stop lying about Palace
entry they can't they're drug addicts
they're addicted to the lies now and
their own conspiracy theories but it
doesn't help it doesn't help the people
it helps the people to know what tax
reform in health care reform really do
see that's going to help they see you
clearly know all right oh I agree Kelly
I'm good the approval ratings I